to rock these [ __ ] out
get up it's a beautiful day to be alive
you're in [ __ ] america
you're not laying there with flies on
you and white people taking pictures of
you and [ __ ]
let's hope not
what's up
now that i [ __ ] i'm i'm all energized
i [ __ ] stopped me bro i [ __ ] told
you this life is a comic is tough nobody
believes me and [ __ ] and we didn't even
do much i didn't have you out snorting
blow or taking machine guns up the ass
nothing i had you out just [ __ ] i did
that on my own okay that's my thing you
went back to the room you were [ __ ]
hallucinating it's great to be back
happy monday to everybody at churchill
what's happening now
talking about austin texas thank you
very much for the love and the support
you guys uh showed last week and
and as [ __ ] as far as comedy clubs are
concerned
when i got back i called larry and i
told ari what i thought that club is
definitely
definitely the top five solid clubs in
the country the staff i want to thank
them all
from chandra to kevin to the wait staff
i mean uh
when you go to texas you feel like
family anyway yeah this was just a great
weekend and i'm happy that lee
got to see it firsthand we brought a
camera down we were going to tape a mad
flavors world for you but i don't know
what the [ __ ] happened i got i got a i
got a little bit but [ __ ]
you got me so high and then i was
manning the table man the table [ __ ]
sucked so i was like walking away taking
pictures leaving the t-shirts out duck
sucker man
you were [ __ ] great it was a lot of
fun it's great to watch you interact
with uh
you know man we're not uh we're not just
a podcast no more we're a [ __ ] we're
our own crime family we're our own
[ __ ] crime family that's it that's it
you want to be in the crime family you
got it [ __ ]
but we don't kill nobody we're not
shaking nobody down we're just slinging
dick and telling [ __ ] what time
it is that's it i'm making progress
every [ __ ] day so
you want to be part of something you're
part of a [ __ ] crime family now we
smoke dope i smoke dope finally i didn't
smoke yesterday though no
no i just wanted to smoke in austin it
was my 90 day anniversary
and i wanted to get out of the way and
you know what
i'm quitting again
no big deal for right now yeah i'm
pretty happy with the vapers i mean i
can see you once like the saturday night
shows if they haven't yet yeah i don't
know i have a good time you know i just
i have the best weed
out right now at my house
i looked at it when i got back last
night like you have 90 day old weed i
have uh we somebody gave me about three
weeks ago okay and it is
it's just just to look at it just even
looking at it
and he told me when he gave it to me
goes this is this is it because i don't
have a lot of it take what i have so i'm
just holding it out i'm gonna wait for
my resistance to keep getting lower and
lower
or whatever the [ __ ] it is higher and
higher i ate a pot cookie last night i
had
i had to i told you that how good was
that flight oh i i didn't i don't know i
don't know the way home doctor dog you
had a middle seat open
nobody bothers you you're back in l.a by
[ __ ] 8 30. it wasn't even traffic by
8 30 on a sunday people aren't even
thinking of driving you're back already
yeah and that's it we were home by 9 30
i had a bowl of pasta fazool i was with
the baby and my wife before they went to
church when they came back we took a nap
got up went to the park went to a couple
spots and that's it answered some emails
that's like we had so many [ __ ]
emails last week how to break it into
two parts
and the first time in two years wow
[ __ ] craziness you know a lot a lot
of great questions a lot of people just
reaching out saying uh
but austin you know when i was leaving
there i was thinking how great of a
little city it is just a little city
that has everything yeah and we didn't
do much you know you would have got some
barbecue yeah i i like just because i
thought you were getting like
i have i have a little voice in my head
now jody's voice so we didn't do much
like i didn't want to like not that you
told you didn't tell me not to bother
you but you have the show and i didn't
want to i don't want to like call you
like hey you want to go sightseeing
so
it was like saturday you know saturday
lunch time i was like what can we have
delivered here and all that was
available was chinese food i was like if
i tell joey i got chinese food what's
that [ __ ] yeah we got chinese
i went and looked and the closest place
to me was this place called rudy's i got
a cab and it was [ __ ] delicious it
was [ __ ] amazing you know listen and
i know that there's franklin's and
there's the other place
i got a big problem ladies and gentlemen
i'm gonna tell you what it is right now
i don't believe in lines
and this isn't just recently this is
something that i had even as a young kid
like being i was always very impatient
in lines [ __ ] it if i gotta wait this
long
i don't mind uh a 15-minute line you
know there's lines you have to go
through at security
at the airport i make the best of them
but i don't want to make it a habit to
get online right uh when i was a kid
when i was about 18 or 19 i was taken to
studio 54 on a thursday night
and i was placed online it was a little
bit annoying but my friend got us in and
we were in there like 40 minutes and
studios something else you're in there
doing blow and you get your dick sucked
i didn't get my dick sucked but i'm just
saying you can have sex in there and see
celebrities so i could see
somebody in the 80s but i'm not standing
online for eggs and i'm not i'm a fat
[ __ ]
you know i'm not standing on one for
three hours for [ __ ] barbie i'm just
not i don't care how good the thing is
it's this new and they do it in los
feliz they do it in uh anywhere where
they're hipsters they have lines and you
know what man that works for hipsters i
don't know what you're trying to push
out there i have nothing against you but
i don't believe in standout lines we're
[ __ ] americans man my mother didn't
come from cuba for me to stand online
for [ __ ] three hours for anything
right for [ __ ] anything i just don't
believe in it you know you got to put up
customer service you got to get a table
out there and [ __ ] cut some [ __ ]
brisket out there i'm just not doing it
i i love your product i love what you
stand for but i'm not waiting [ __ ]
three hours i got better [ __ ] to do my
life man i i don't know if this is what
franklin is doing but i think some of it
is
they're creating a demand like a lot of
these places run out of food how many of
you ever have a restaurant running out
of food like i think they're just doing
it so people know they're going to run
out people know there's a line so then
you're going to go and it's like
you know what i'm not paying somebody
what i want i'm not doing that to
somebody else i'm not the type of person
i'm not gonna wait online i'm gonna pay
you 10 bucks an hour long i'll pay you
50 bucks down the line for three hours
but i'm just not gonna do it i'm not
supporting that [ __ ] rudy's was in the
gas station and it was [ __ ] delicious
no no not society now it's this thing
that you know iphones it's hip to stand
online the night before you know what
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] you you want to smoke a half a
number and stay online for an hour and
giggle with your friends for 40 minutes
that's cool but i'm not going to be
there all [ __ ] i'm not part of that's
a sign i never watched i think that's
the worst one and don't hey don't be mad
at me if you're one of the ones that did
it
but with amazon now in the and ordering
online it comes the same day yeah no no
it's it's it's a part of this thing this
movement that we stood online listen
then move to [ __ ] russia stand online
for everything toilet paper light bulbs
do do your [ __ ] thing don't be
standing online on a [ __ ] day i'm
just not [ __ ] doing it i don't care
it's just something my mother didn't
come from cube i just don't like it man
and that's it that's why i [ __ ] stand
and i know the barbecue is good at
franklin i had it last time i went it's
[ __ ] delicious the brisket melts in
your mouth but not three hours worth no
no no no no no even the [ __ ] jesus
was born what's up lee nothing everyone
was so cool can you show that that model
again that was the [ __ ] everyone was
so nice in texas that's that's the day
the devil was buried in c
this is from uh andrew and i don't know
how to
pronounce her last name yes minnie she's
[ __ ] sweet
they're very nice people we met a lot of
nice people man and uh this is
everywhere now this is everywhere you
know we're doing a podcast we don't come
on here and uh
what we go off
but we uh try to make you leave here
feeling good it's like a [ __ ] disney
movie you know the church what's
happening i was like this it's like
going to see the love bug so are you the
princess or am i whatever you know
a little distressed i never said i was
no princess
i'm not saying about that [ __ ]
what i'm saying is that you know uh we
have a family so you're part of
something i'm part of some lease part or
something like i said in the beginning
i'm with you you're with me and they're
with us [ __ ] them all and if they're not
with us [ __ ] them all who gives a [ __ ]
who needs them you know what i'm saying
exactly who the [ __ ] needs them lee no
what do you got today what were you
asking me about my schedule no i just
you we were talking and i i have uh rick
grandmas tonight okay um but other than
that i'm [ __ ]
no nothing like mariah 4.
i got my last voice over class at seven
i'm gonna
uh work out i gotta write a little bit
today i gotta meet with uh my girl
tomorrow wednesday for the book
and that's it the the things are uh
everything's [ __ ] rolling
smoothly you know i love it
i'm still i i'm still getting over all
those edibles that was a crazy
[ __ ] three or four days dave wilder
you know oh my gosh [ __ ] cuban
pastries from dallas i'm going to give
him a shout out ookie spooky came down
with her son looking beautiful
it was just uh a nice little
get-together now we're gonna hook up
with lady jay i mean
it's amazing what this is becoming and i
never dreamt this i thought it was just
gonna be you and i cracking stupid
[ __ ] jokes and people but no it's
becoming something beautiful i'll tell
you what was the most impressive thing
of the weekend was doug benson's show
when i walked in then i seen people with
signs like let's make a [ __ ] deal
i just could not believe it i was blown
the [ __ ] away i couldn't even believe
you know there's only two movies with
the letters oh and basically that i know
oh yeah yeah other people's money and on
the waterfront
at first i was so high with the edible
that apocalypse now came
apocalypse now i go no apocalypse it's a
[ __ ] egg
but uh no no it was uh
that was amazing doug does a great job
with that goddamn show and trey was
funny and joe was funny the kids i
worked with this weekend it was just a
total complete [ __ ] uh
great weekend to get on that was it
eight weeks in a row i did people jesus
eight weeks of stand up seven planes
in eight weeks seven [ __ ] return
flights in seven weeks okay that's a lot
of [ __ ] plans
but i did it and it wasn't even for the
money man it was just to see you people
at this point
i love i want to see the people i talk
to stand up has become something
different for me now
i want to talk to the people and uh i
got these dates in new york
at gotham i don't know what the official
date is but it's either these two weeks
in september and so i'm gonna get a
theater in brooklyn and lee and i gonna
go to new york we're taking this [ __ ]
podcast in new york we're gonna have
some of my buddies on there maybe some
crooked [ __ ] gangsters and [ __ ] we're
gonna do a [ __ ] live podcast
somewhere in new york and we'll keep you
posted on that uh
i don't you know it's funny this weekend
because lee asked me
how i thought i did on stage you know uh
we talk comedy on here and stand up and
and little things it's like when i go to
jiu jitsu if i go to jiu jitsu when i
last 10 more seconds i did the session
before i'm very happy if i go to jiu
jitsu and i do a hip escape and uh
i i [ __ ] uh sweep you and then i tap
out because i can't breathe i'm very
happy because i made forward progress it
was funny that i thought i was having
mediocre sets and then
i did some i write
for me sometimes to write a joke i have
to write a story and then when i'm
writing the story i think of something
that all turns together then the story i
was writing is irrelevant i found a joke
somewhere and one day i was writing a
story and i think we talked about this
in the testicle in time
about sticky charlie we talked about it
a lot of places i think where when we
talk i think i think you talked about it
in a tactical testament i think you've
talked about on the podcast too
sticky charlie was the greasiest looking
dude you ever saw in your life he had
some part it was something and i hate to
say this it was some uh you know it was
1970 so he had some type of
disorder you know and he was a little
older than us i mean he was a lot older
than us we were six or seven he had to
be in his thirties
uh he got a check from the government
maybe okay and he lived with his parents
and i think he was jewish i think he had
that something about him he could have
been you know i'm saying he was just a
white dude but i think he could i'm not
making fun of you hey i'm just saying
i'm sure i think he was jewish he had
that
mom his mom would come looking for him
oh gosh okay he was 30. that's the worst
when you're sniffing the glue
uncle
uh i never knew about drugs i knew that
my mom had smoked pot uh you know i knew
that
little things but i was just a kid i
wasn't aware of it and i was a geek man
when i came from cuba i didn't know how
to speak
so i wouldn't
speak uh constantly you know i was very
insecure about my language and my
american
so i got into building models i don't
know why people don't [ __ ] hate me
for i got into building ships and little
[ __ ] buildings but then the marvel
series came out and they had the hulk
breaking through a wall and they had
like spider-man on a wall with a web and
there were like these elaborate models
and me and this geeky kid would get
together 148th street of all places on
top of this hobby store it was like they
had you know paintings and and greeting
cards whatever and we would do these
models in the summer and then once we
finished we'd go out we let them dry so
we put them together and then i'd paint
them and you'd paint them he had a
better hand than me he did the eyeballs
and the and the star on captain america
and i should i mean we were a team don't
ask me what his name was i don't
remember what his name was but that was
our life and we would meet like that
like the model store opened at nine we
were there at nine
i bought the model but he helped me
okay okay and then we split it somewhere
another we i gave it to him or whatever
i bring it back home
and uh one morning i got up i don't know
what happened with the circumstances we
got all you know when you're [ __ ]
when you're a kid you don't know nothing
about anything being out of stock
you know what i'm saying when you're a
kid and you go buy sneakers
you they better be a [ __ ] stock you
don't know nothing about somebody saying
to you
oh we have them on stock we have to come
back right like out of stock what does
that mean so me and this geeky kid went
into this [ __ ] glue store into this
hobby store and went to get our glue and
the guy's like no i'm out of it i'm
clean out of it and for some reason at
that time at that time a couple people
knew
charlie snorted glue but i don't think
these two [ __ ] store owners knew that
he started glue you know and it was
weird how we we caught him in my
godmother's alleyway
and what he would do is he put the glue
in a bag and then you blow in it like
yeah attack or something
all right you did a lot of drugs i
didn't do it i know i didn't do glue i
know you didn't do glue you've done a
lot of drugs in your day
how does someone get to the point where
they're doing glue i don't [ __ ] know
lee i don't know i think for him it was
a starting point and he got stuck there
he got that yeah i think he just got
stuck in that phase you know sometimes
you smoke pot and then you do mess going
for a while then you do coke then you do
heroin he just settled on glue
and i think and that's what makes me
think after more thinking that he was
jewish because he got a a government
check at the beginning of the month and
he had to chop up his days into a budget
so what fits into a two dollar budget
glue
it's 35 cents a [ __ ] tube
so after i saw him snorting the glue i
didn't know like it took me like a week
to ask around and people like yeah yeah
yeah
so i'm like i had to wait four [ __ ]
days for that glue we had to walk like a
half a mile to get the other glue that
you had to take out and with a brush and
brush and you can't build the model
rubber cement you can't build a model
with that so we will live it
so i thought i started thinking this is
this is why i i don't want people to
think that i had a bad life like people
like oh well you know his mom died no
man i was i was doomed for failure from
the age of six and it was because of
sticky charlie put a curse on me he put
a [ __ ] glue curse on me those are
worse than [ __ ] any black person
could put on you so [ __ ] sticky
i figured out that now at this point
we'll call them sticky charlie
right me these puerto rican kids nelson
and ricky i forget what his uh sedan
we're calling him sticky charlie sticky
charlie's thinking charlie so i get
pissed off this is the only time i
ratted somebody out so i went into the
store another time they're like yeah we
have like i went back and they were down
to three tubes so from being out of
stock now they're down to three tubes so
i just bought all three [ __ ] tubes
and i said that's it i know he's i go
when are you getting the next shipment
he goes what are you talking about when
you get in the next shipment he goes i
don't know it takes like two days to
order i go [ __ ] it let me i'm six or
seven i go let me know how much a box of
glue is i'm gonna call my mom right now
and i'll have a send you the money the
guy's looking like what are you talking
about i didn't [ __ ] around at that age
what i just have this image of the girl
back there the the guy with you in the
suit
that's just you running around yeah
that's me i was younger than that
oh that's so funny that's when i was 10.
this is three years earlier and my
mother i remember taking a [ __ ] cab
down to 88 street and she gave me like
the 15 bucks
like she didn't understand i'm like i'm
gonna be a business owner and she's like
what are you talking about like at that
age she didn't even question me so you
weren't hoarding it for yourself no i
[ __ ] went and bought all the glue so
i could sell it to sticky
something in my mind just said this is
the only way i'm going to control the
glue [ __ ] trade i i'm never going to
be without glue again
that would bro that's what it was that's
what our life was how can i live without
[ __ ] glue i didn't want to use rubber
[ __ ] cemently so i went and ratted
the guy out i go you know this guy
snorts [ __ ] glue how can you keep
[ __ ] sound going i bought the case of
glue so i waited for sticky charlie
stick the store opened at like the nine
okay i got there like at 8 30 one more
and that's sticky charlie scratching
and he's like i don't know what happened
they threw me out of that i'm not
allowed in there no more for some reason
[ __ ] i'm not allowed at the hardware
store like three blocks away it was like
another hardware store 150
in amsterdam or something he wasn't
allowed in there either the people from
that store called those people so they
started calling each other and telling
them that that guy was snorting glue and
they don't want him in the stores so he
knew it he's like so do me a favor go in
there and buy me the [ __ ] glue i went
in there i said no i'm not gonna buy the
glue i got the glue now
i'm the new [ __ ] king of the glue on
this corner [ __ ] you want glue
it's going to cost you 55 cents he was
best he's like so you're putting a 20
cents tariff on it
i'm like guys and i didn't even know
about the law and supply i knew nothing
i just knew i was a glue salesman i
didn't know about marketing skills there
was no myspace there was no nothing i
just knew this [ __ ] was not
taking my glue no more and this went on
for a summer where he would come to me
and go come on give me the glue for 45
cents so you're not getting it for 45
it's 55 [ __ ] cents he would tell me
[ __ ] you i'm gonna rob you anyway
because i hung out with like three other
[ __ ] little devils that that was six
and seven and [ __ ] we bite you and we
hit you with [ __ ] garbage cans we
didn't give a [ __ ] where did you keep
the glue did you have a little briefcase
godmother's house he'd give me the money
i'd go to the [ __ ] spot and didn't
come back i wouldn't put it in my pocket
i put him and my godmother's like what's
all this glue
so he started teasing me saying i'll
give you 35 cents i ain't paying you a
dime over so i would get elmer's glue to
[ __ ] with him and you can't snort i
don't miss glue there's nothing that was
good but the best of the day he told me
to go [ __ ] myself
at nine in the morning and that one i
saw him across the street with a can of
paint oh mix
mixing it up and he would start like
he's not a pain he's snoring paint the
little you know little ones no you have
the big cans of paint okay you get the
little cans of paint oh like the uh yeah
put that in the bag mix it up a little
bit and he would wait for a hot day or
so i don't [ __ ] know lee i don't know
that's the worst that's one of the worst
and he used to get pimples on his neck
from snorting glute like whiteheads oh
but they weren't filled with glue they
were filled with like
just parts of liquid
i don't [ __ ] know i tortured that
[ __ ] for two or three years
finally i don't know where he went he
went to a glue rehab or some [ __ ]
speaking of torturing
the
that lady at the end of saturday night
was possibly my favorite lady ever oh
what that [ __ ] old lady was
tremendous an old lady and she was
waiting for you
and then you left i thought you were
going to the club to like try to hide
from her so i was like i was standing
out there high as [ __ ] just like staring
at her and then you came out and it took
like 15 minutes to get rid of her listen
dog some women some people never mind
women men who are relentless
she was relentless she came up to me
saying that she was an author
and she wanted to ask me questions now
this lady had to be 56 to 60.
she's telling me she had to ask me
questions about uh a book or whatever so
i go what's the book about and she
started telling me about what is that
[ __ ] s and m
a handcuff on her wrist that's not my
world
you know i'll piss on your neck i'll do
[ __ ] like that but i've never tied
somebody up and dragged them across the
room and punched them like that that's
just me goofing around that's not in my
repertoire of sex moves and all she kept
saying all because i had i ended up
leaving with joe just because i couldn't
keep it together and i won't ruin it but
all she kept saying was let's have a
drink let's have a coffee and you're
like i can't i gotta go right now
what am i gonna do have a drink but i
don't even know what the [ __ ] to drink
i'm coffee it's one in the [ __ ]
morning go home old lady jesus christ
torturing me she followed you to the car
oh my god
i even asked her no and then i knew i
was in trouble when she told me she was
bald from my eyebrows down
i didn't know what that meant
no what the [ __ ] she meant i was like
jesus so she's bawled from my [ __ ]
eyebrows down i i didn't know what the
[ __ ] she was talking about
it's amazing the people you meet man you
meet interesting people at all levels
and at the end of the game that's what
this is all about remember for years
that was the big the word is whatever
you talk to me what do you want to do
with your life oh i want to travel and
meet interesting people the [ __ ] are you
talking about now it's what i do yeah i
travel and i meet interesting people
it's that [ __ ] simple ever you ever
have a pimp on top of your eyebrow
probably there's no white head or
nothing but the [ __ ] hurts like
a [ __ ]
jesus christ this thing hurts i just
want to give her the squeeze i thought
somebody stuck a [ __ ] meal in my
eyeball
one of
jesus christ almighty
i watched something very interesting the
other night that really tapped home with
me
and it had to do with artie lang i
watched audio lang on tom green i think
it was thursday night i had radio friday
morning yeah
first off tom green is becoming a great
little and [ __ ] interviewer i mean
his shows uh i've watched a couple of
them and america's ready for that type
of [ __ ] something lose-free
where people curse and whatnot
and uh
you know he talked to hardy about what
had happened for you a lot of people
don't know artie
was a co-host on the uh
howard stern show
i never really listened i think in the
eight years he was on there i listened
to him maybe three times
and every time i listened to him it
scared me because he sounded like me and
i was doing all those drugs and stuff
and i had never known artie i met him in
vegas briefly
we did a show
uh with rogan me ari duncan and they
were doing the show later on that
midnight
and their show was four times the size
of ours like we thought we were badasses
because we had 600 people yeah he must
have had 8 000 people in there and he
was hammered
and he went on stage and it was like uh
it was sad i remember even as a junkie
myself saying that sad i would never
want
uh
people to know me for that you know we
smoke a joint we have a few jaegers
but to be on stage inebriated and be
[ __ ] up and and you know one thing
about audie langman when he gives an
interview
he's very honest so i i feel
what you guys feel sometimes when i talk
about drugs or or situations or uh
and he was talking about what had
happened to him at the end when he tried
to commit suicide and how howard called
him but they put him in the insane
asylum and uh
you know because when you try to kill
yourself they they hold you down they
tie your hands and [ __ ] you know and
the paparazzis and he was talking about
how he's a c-level
uh
celebrity and the paparazzi was still
there and it's just amazing where uh
the drugs had taken him and it's funny
when i talk about drugs in front of
least sometimes i see it in lee's face
that he doesn't know like lee it's just
a ha i'm very happy that you you're who
you are
you know i i don't understand uh
i understand how it did work the message
from people did work because i talked to
a lot of young people yeah i talked to a
lot of young people that take action and
go to raves and [ __ ] like that
but i talk to a lot of young people i
don't even know what that is and you're
one of them and it's amazing that
sometimes when i talk about drugs you
sit there and go wow
i'm so [ __ ] happy i didn't get
involved i'm so it's it's you cannot
when i was watching that interview and i
was watching
already talk about the drugs and uh
just the aftermath of the suicide thing
i couldn't never imagine that and i
gotta tell you man
the last year and a half i was that
frustrated jesus i don't know how i
didn't stick a knife in myself no i
can't even imagine because i've had some
low times just naturally and i can't
even imagine having the drug addiction
it's true we have shitty time just being
a human being
never mind pouring that [ __ ] into your
nose or your veins but there was times
when i would have to go in the bathroom
and pee
and i would look at myself in the mirror
and feel the love of christ lee i can't
tell you what i felt inside
i felt like the mirror was going right
through me
you want to just put your head through
the mirror so you can't really see
yourself so what's the feeling like
like when you have like that like he
let's say he's so pissed off he's that
depressed
but he's still using is it like do you
hate yourself while you're doing it is
it absolutely stupid does it still feel
good
no no
no no no you just uh
you're putting it more in you to kill
the pain to kill what you just saw yeah
hope the image go out of your mind i
mean and the image is horrible when you
walk past the bathroom and you see
yourself or
the next day when somebody takes a
picture and you see yourself it's it's a
[ __ ] horrible i've always
if you really scour you'll never find
pictures of me coked up i always hated
that [ __ ]
people wanted to take pictures and they
were coked up for me
it was something i was involved in that
it was a dirty little secret you know it
just kept going yeah at least sometimes
it keeps going it's a runaway [ __ ]
train you know if i get 90 emails a week
30 of them are about pills or yeah coke
or heroin it's a runaway [ __ ] train
and
once a person gets off and looks inside
themselves it's [ __ ] scary it's a
deep scary move so now you have two
choices after you look inside yourself
you could either keep going or go for
help
and i'm gonna tell you something keeping
going is the easiest choice look at this
you know sometimes i remember trying to
go for help i remember trying to go to a
free clinic in hollywood
just to see what it was about and it was
a [ __ ] nightmare
so by the time you took the paperwork to
go get it you were getting high again it
just didn't matter yeah i mean i
remember terry finding the paperwork one
thing going what the [ __ ] is this and i
stopped by there for a friend
and heard giggling her ass off going
jesus christ i can't believe you can't
but that was the very beginning yeah
it's crazy
because when you're talking about how
kids don't get into it there's do you
have dare when you're a kid i don't it's
just a drug program they come in no no
no they come to your schools and they
show you the stupid videos and it never
really works
and i don't know if you it would be
scared straight
but i mean it does work i think it would
be what i'm saying i think it would be
better if like someone like you or artie
lang would go and be like listen guys
like it feels great at the beginning
but it never ends up positive like
that's that's all when you were saying
that that it never it it stops feeling
good if i went into a classroom of 60
people and talk to 60 kids
i would reach one of them
yeah one of the 60 kids because
30 of those kids wouldn't get high
anyway
okay uh 50 i'm going with 50
and i'm not intelligent in that source
i'm just saying what i feel that's fine
i think 50 would be 15 kids out of 30
kids out of 60 and i could probably
scare one kid not scare one kid but
uh confirm what he was thinking he had
an idea he was thinking and getting high
listen kids are going to smoke pot
yeah it's just something if they don't
uh
it's kind of weird because they're
trying things you know you try things
when you're younger
or maybe you're not you're that
headstrong and that solid your parents
did such a good job i don't even know if
it's that i think i don't think i think
parents can do a great job but it's just
i mean you must see it at a very
much more intense level with mercy
because everything's new but when you
think about it when i mean
the first time you tried drinking it's
not because you want to be an alcoholic
but it's new and you're not supposed to
do it and
but you can't compete like i can't
compete when i go in to talk to 60 kids
about doing drugs
i can't compete with society i can't
compete with instagram
right i can't compete with somebody
being at a club and taking a picture of
themselves smoking a blunt
you know i can't compete of the coolness
of that
and deep down inside we all want to be
accepted we all want to be cool we all
want to be
so i can't compete with that if i know
what i know now i can tell you that you
don't need to [ __ ] do drugs to be
cool i think you'd be [ __ ] cooler
without [ __ ] doing drugs that's if if
you live your life in that matter you
know i know a lot of people don't do
drugs that live their life
and they have a great [ __ ] time i was
weak at that age and i let them come in
and then they stayed in you know i let
them come in and they stayed in and
little by little i got rid of
the the damage was it too late was it
too early who the [ __ ] knows i know i'm
not doing drugs today yeah i know i'm
not they're not on my mind constantly
and now what do you think
aren't you interested to get your uh
perspective on it
when i was under 21 i drank a lot and
then when it was legal for me i
basically stopped drinking at 21. i
believe that what do you feel about like
that countries are legalizing more and
more drugs do you think it's a good
thing or i don't like it you don't
really i don't want i don't want it in
their faces man
i don't want it in everybody's faces i
know how it affects me you want me to
really
i left new york for various reasons but
one reason definitely
definitely was the accessibility of it
the accessibility of cocaine in the 80s
it wasn't the big thing i could walk to
the [ __ ] corner okay i could walk to
the corner there'd be three guys sitting
out there talking and inside a bumper in
a car nearby they had coke stashed all i
had to do was give them the cash and
they'd send that boy to go get it right
on my [ __ ] corner you know heroin was
acceptable when i was a kid i could go
to washington square park and get eight
valiums for ten dollars when i was
eighteen years old
eight thousands for ten dollars ten
[ __ ] dollars guys ten dollars you
know
and i just didn't like that
accessibility and i know i'm gonna get
well
listen people are gonna do drugs anyway
yeah people gonna drink people gonna
[ __ ] [ __ ] and suck people gonna get
hookers people gonna shoot heroin people
gonna gamble you know
uh i i saw a report months ago maybe a
year on the
backlash of gambling in pennsylvania all
these women all these housewives that go
to these games and these games are
are
lights and bolts and they get caught up
and they next you know that they're
remortgaging their house these women
their husbands don't know you know when
i went down to santa fe
somebody had won uh uh an account and
the guy was telling me one of the
managers there he goes it was [ __ ] up
because they wanted the 60 grand in cash
you know not in the check that means
that they don't want their husband to
know they won the 60 grand oh jesus you
know it's things as simple as gambling
now are they weak for getting involved
with gambling yeah did i gamble yeah did
i learn my lesson you know how you learn
your lesson when you gamble when you pay
three weeks when you lose that's how you
learn your lesson if you keep losing
then it's a mental thing it becomes a
mental thing where you enjoy losing you
enjoy saying jesus [ __ ] christ i had
the jets minus three and you know some
people that's a form of conversation
going to be expressive
i just i don't know man i don't like it
and i'm telling you this is a [ __ ]
junkie that that's why i'm thinking
about this as a [ __ ] junkie that i i
don't want it that accessible okay i do
not want it that accessible i know when
i was out there you're going to get it
anyway but you don't want it over the
[ __ ] counter so any good that would
come from not having to go to drug
dealers is it just it's negated by the
fact that now there's heroin on the
streets
there's always going to be drugs on the
street right there's going to be [ __ ]
meth everywhere you know i was telling
you i watched on that geo the other
night
i watched drugs inc and i was watching a
guy in san francisco it's part of a gay
meth ring up there that they hooked on
[ __ ] meth and this guy dresses up
like [ __ ] rob halfer from judas
priest and for 200 miles an hour he
comes to your house and he's got hiv
he's got hiv already and he shoots matt
and then once a month the guy sends him
a thousand dollars he gets a hotel room
because he's homeless by the way gets a
hotel room gets a computer with a camera
and tapes himself shooting heroin and
jerking off and the guy pays him a
thousand dollars
[ __ ] hilarious jesus christ [ __ ]
hilarious so if people are doing that
it's [ __ ] uh uh still illegal you
imagine legal and people gonna do them
and people are gonna get drugs at all
levels and i
i'm not i can't [ __ ] judge you i
can't you know i i've been where you
[ __ ] been you know but something
about it i just didn't want it that easy
man is that part of the reason why
you're not smoking as much because
i mean especially with mercy getting
older she's gonna start seeing things
and with edibles and stuff you can't no
one's gonna know what that she's not
gonna know what that is but if like she
saw he was like a joint that'd be easier
to see
is that any part of your thinking at all
listen man
let's get the [ __ ] let's push the
elephant out of the room
uh your parents are your heroes or at
least this is how i feel
if you've heard this podcast if you know
anything about me
my mother was my hero and then she died
so you have a fallen [ __ ] hero okay
i'm not even going there with it but we
have parents they're our heroes until a
certain age your parents are your
[ __ ] heroes you want to be your
father
girls want to be mommy you know they
want to be princesses whatever the [ __ ]
they want to be okay
what if you saw your hero
doing something
what if you saw your hero yeah how many
times have people said jesus christ they
went to meet jerry lewis and he told
them to go [ __ ] themselves and they left
their depressed or whatever
it's the same thing with your parents i
saw my hero
get high i didn't [ __ ] like it when i
was a kid you know many times i told my
mom to wipe her nose because i would see
the coat rings and [ __ ] jesus i [ __ ]
hated that i'm being honest with you
guys
i hated it but at some point it had to
affect me it told me it was okay to do
it yeah somewhere okay if your hero does
it tells you it's okay to do it we have
a responsibility here in this country
around the world you have a
responsibility especially people on the
public eye you know people in the public
eye you know these little girls love kim
kardashian you know how many people are
making sex tape because they think that
they put a sex tape up they're going to
be famous whatever there's different
thing you know this chick right here
with sterling
what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] i'm still blown away that
a pretty girl there's got to be a
retardation in there somewhere that
makes you want to suck an old dick to
pay your [ __ ] rent there's a lot of
those people now i mean there's there's
a show coming out
where the the commercial forward is this
girl saying the only skill i want to
have is signing a credit card receipt
and it's just
people and not just for this town some
of them have a lot of money like parents
just don't care and they give them money
instead of what a pathetic life but you
know also signed a night like that when
he was [ __ ] boy
me
jesus that was the life i wanted i
didn't want to do [ __ ] i thought i had
money i thought i had money coming to me
i thought the world owed me
you know when i walked into a bar i
could drink for free i thought that i
could front coke you know we all want
that world we all want that world where
we just walk into a place and there's a
lamborghini waiting for you but
that's not a [ __ ] reality have you
heard a lot of that i mean
obviously i'm not asking you to name
names but in hollywood have you heard of
like this this actor has a 20 year old
girl who lives in the hills and he pays
her rent and
yeah you heard a lot of jesus christ i
knew about it uh
i first discovered it when i was [ __ ]
guys
this is just to tell you how naive i was
about those sexual type things
because i don't want you to think that i
knew everything about every i didn't i
learned them the hard way just like you
guys we're all [ __ ] morons and as we
go along we learn things when i was 20
no [ __ ] 95.
when i was 32 i dated a girl and i liked
them one day we were talking and she
goes do you know how i put myself
through college
and that was how and she goes i had an
old man
but i [ __ ] him once a week and he paid
my college he paid my car bill
he paid all my bills and gave me 500 a
week
and she'd have to go over there once a
week and he'd get another hooker
and uh she would have to suck his dick
while the hooker ate her [ __ ] and do
blow it was [ __ ] craziness now like
at first when you first said you're like
oh that's gross
but like imagine
let's say you were a girl instead
is that so bad i mean like if you were a
girl and your mom died and you were on
your own and there was no way for her to
get through college
maybe that's not terrible listen i i
can't judge it because what's there
between me is stealing
and her hooking i mean we're both
selling our [ __ ] souls yeah
you know so i'm not here to judge i was
never mad at her but i had never heard
that before yeah 32 years old we got a
call coming
what's up baby
dude
it's my main man johnny gumbaz
what's happening ray canela
not much not much not much i am uh i am
just uh
doing my thing on a monday morning uh
jenny i'm opening up the office here and
uh
just uh
just getting ready to attack culture
once again never in the history of the
podcast has i have i had so many people
ask when are you going to put ray back
on so i was talking to lee about
television the other day and uh whatever
and i said i gotta get [ __ ] right
back on lee said the same thing and here
the [ __ ] you are what's happened
beautiful
nothing nothing nothing i'm having a
good old time i'm i'm finally enjoying
uh uh spring has finally strung in new
jersey after a really really shitty
winter and uh uh i'm dude i'm just i'm
doing my thing i'm very excited you know
uh uh
i'm uh i'm gearing up to relaunch
uh our subscription horror movie channel
screen box all right so tell me what
happened tell me what happened because
lee was asking
how's the youtube page going
well uh uh what screenbox is is
screenbox is a digital horror movie
channel uh much like netflix in that you
pay a small monthly fee and you have
access to our horror film library
okay you can watch as many movies as you
want as many turns as you want
and like netflix
there's no ads no commercials everything
is completely uncut there's no pop-ups
there's no promos you have to scroll
through nothing
you pay a fee and you watch
the material you watch the content
we had launched a screen box a year ago
on youtube
and now i am knee deep in work
uh uh getting ready to relaunch screen
box on july 15
across multiple platforms uh we are uh
set to launch on xbox
on roku and on samsung uh devices
in addition to launching an official
website
so uh this is the next step this is the
next move we're gonna uh the youtube
channel is going to become a marketing
platform
and i believe it's going to become a
free channel so you can come to
the youtube screen box channel and
you'll see me and you'll see trailers
and you'll see uh movie reviews and lots
of fun stuff going on there and if you'd
like to become a subscriber well then
you can link on over to our website and
become a subscriber and for 2.99 a month
you gain access to all of our films
and it's just the natural evolution of
uh of entertainment really because i
know that you and i want to talk a
little bit about the cable and broadcast
uh
upfront that occurred uh a week or two
ago
and you know before getting into that
topic
what i'm excited about
is the work i'm doing right now
uh being involved with good people at
screen box the team has really grown
since we launched a year ago
and we have wonderful wonderful creative
talented people involved to really take
screen box to the next level
and um
we think this is the future of
entertainment it's a vod world you know
it's a video on demand world uh people
are no longer satisfied with
shelling out you know hundreds of
dollars for cable
and uh not watching you know and not
watching any of it
you you you're simply not watching what
you're paying for with cable
um
you get how many how many channels you
get at home coco
600
yeah
and you watch
between nine
and fourteen of them
out of all those channels you are only
watching between nine and fourteen it is
not a good value anymore cable tv now
when you and i were young when you and i
were kids
and cable started
what was the benefit to cable back in
the day do you remember getting dirty
movies on hbo the first hbo i got was
because of the groove tube
i talked my mind
even before hbo
even before it's because hbo didn't come
along
right away
the goal that the the mean benefit of
cable back in the day
was the reception
it eliminated the need for an antenna on
the top of your home
by having cable that was the benefit
back in the day
and then they started adding channels
and having channels when i was with the
sci-fi channel back in 1992 when we
launched the sci-fi
uh the cable net the cable landscape was
still analog
okay and we had trouble
getting on
cable systems
because the digital wage hadn't hadn't
come yet everything was still antiquated
analog equipment when the digital age
came that's when everything exploded and
now you've got 600 channels and then
each broadcast channel has an on-demand
channel which isn't really on demand
because you still have to sit through
commercials
you know i it's very funny just last
night
my wife and i
were
going through the on-demand channels
because each network like abc and cbs
and nbc and fox they also have what they
call a vod channel
but in my opinion it's not really vod
when you have to sit through commercials
you know it's just
another cbs channel let me tell you
something that i like what you did
something that we talk a lot about in
the church that
you did and i admire the [ __ ] out of you
that you couldn't do
30 years ago
was a man in his late 40s early 50s
saying
[ __ ] the corporate world or [ __ ] my job
i'm going to go out there and do
something different
i'm going to go out there and do
something that while i was doing this
[ __ ] job and i was loving it i was
learning something i was seeing the bad
side of it or the downs i'm not saying
sci-fi was bad in any way i watch it
from time to time what i'm saying is
that that's what i admire about you at
this point that you're saying that at
midlife you're gonna go [ __ ] what i was
doing i'm gonna go open up my real
[ __ ] passion and put everything i got
into it until they put me in the [ __ ]
grave and one of these horror movies
that i produce myself well
the truth the truth is while that's
while that's very nice of you to say the
truth is that
the truth is that i i i was let go from
sci-fi okay well even that i'm no
visionary no even that ray even that
even a lot of people how long were you
there how long were you at sci-fi how
long were you there 20 years okay most
people would have [ __ ] climbed into a
hole gone to a doctor taking
antidepressants and blamed it on society
and how a guy your age what is he gonna
do now not you not you you said you know
what i'm gonna turn to my passion i put
away a couple dollars i got a brother i
got a wife and i'm gonna go to work and
i'm doing what i love and that's why i
admire you look you tried the youtube
page last night when i spoke to you you
spoke to me about this youtube page
because you know what it didn't work out
like we thought so we're going to attack
this most people crawl in a [ __ ] rock
ray
yeah i mean i i don't know a lot about
the business side but it seems like
you're making the right choice yeah
youtube is a good place to start because
it has the the backbone and has people
going to youtube but now now that you
have a little bit of a following you go
and you go to your own website and you
don't have to deal with youtube anymore
well you know the the powers that be the
uh
the good people that created screen box
and i'm i'm now and and to be clear i'm
not one of the creators of screen box
they approached me
when uh when i became available on the
open market
uh they approached me to be a programmer
and a host
and and uh
you know it's it's just a privilege to
be thought of in such a way
uh but i you know i mean i had already
seen the writing on the wall because i
have two teenage daughters
and you and i spoke about this in the
past my teenage daughters
were obliterating the way that i was
using television
so around the time that you know the
layoffs happened at sci-fi i was let go
with about 400 folks
about around the time that the layoffs
happened at nbc universal
um
i was already
you know
ready to go
because
of a number of things 20 years is a long
time
uh uh you got you have to 20 years of
one particular spot is an awful long
time uh uh you you you need to move
around more and i and i wished that i
had
moved around a little bit more but um
but i also came to the realization that
there was a change coming to the
industry that no one can stop
that
that this change in the industry is
inevitable
and so in a way uh it was it was both of
a blessing and a curse
that i uh i left cable
and uh the good people screenbox were
generous enough to make me an offer and
uh have me come aboard and it's been so
exciting
a huge learning curve for me i think um
you know i'm 51 i just turned 51
and so to be
training in a new technology i've been
sitting through training sessions and
things like that to be trained uh in a
new technology this old dog learning a
few new tricks has been a lot of fun and
i and i could be bothered with it with
all of this
so uh so so for me it's a lot of fun but
i personally feel that
you know i was at a party yesterday and
i was speaking with a 20 year old young
lady a young lady in her mid-20s
who just passed the bar exam
and joined a law firm
okay
she does not
own cable she has a netflix account
and an xbox account
okay
so this is the shift that is happening
the next gens the next generation the
millennials and the next generations
okay they don't want cable they can't
afford it number one
and and it's an on-demand world they
want to watch what they want to watch
they don't want to watch what someone
else selects for them
at a time that is selected for them it's
an on-demand
world and the next generation gets that
and so what you see from the broadcast
channels and from the cable channels
what you're seeing is a lot of
scrambling
they're throwing a lot of money at the
problem
the problem is their audience is
shrinking and their advertising values
are shrinking
and
this is true this is the truth
it's been a steady decline it's a slow
decline because the networks are doing
an excellent job of keeping the quality
of the content up
but nonetheless it's still a decline and
i think over over years we'll see
uh the model shift
and and i mean we are seeing the model
shift but right now television is still
your primary source of entertainment i
could easily foresee a future where uh
it's all on the web
i i think for people my age i don't
think tv is number one anymore i think i
think if sports
weren't a factor it'd be even more
people not on tv because honestly that's
the really only reason i need
cable other than that i could get
anything i need online what do you think
about
and i'm actually really pissed off i
hate att i hate the worst and they just
brought direct tv
and because you saw the news this
morning right yeah about 18t and comcast
just bought freaking time warner
they're only gonna they're all it's
gonna be worse and worse because they're
gonna have even less choices and it's
gonna get more expensive
and it's just it's terra and then out
here for dodgers fans if you don't have
time warner you can't watch dodger games
so now they have no reason to keep
i think they're making terrible
decisions i watched i went i clicked on
a gallery
uh online they have all those picture
galleries like look at the shows that
got cancelled this year
i went through 40 slides and i must have
not known 30 of the shows
all the pilots and stuff that got
canceled i i
you just never hear of them anymore so i
mean i'll be
saturated the mark the cable landscape
is now
saturated um
who announced the other day that they
declined to launch okay i was just
reading in the trades that someone came
out to say oh let's move this
was uh uh making a comment about uh um
you know maybe launching a cbs branded
cable network but at this point the
cable landscape is so saturated there
are so many channels out there that you
had no clue that they existed
um but it's a waste of time and a waste
of space right uh and a list of money
more importantly
um yeah the cable landscape is is is
pretty much
uh uh done and eaten up and 18 t just
spent 48 billion by the way 48 billion
to buy direct tv
i don't know i don't even know how
that's legal but
he has about 25 they have about 25
million subscribers i think between 20
and 25 million subscribers
directv so that's a huge chunk of change
but what that does for atp it puts them
in the tv business it puts them in the
cable business you know a t
um and that's where they want to be
jesus
it's uh it's pretty i think the only tv
stations that really make sense
are like those ones like tbs and all
those ones that just really do
syndicated shows and they don't have to
spend any money on producing the actual
shows tbs does produce a few shows but
like whatever my team like whatever that
weird guy that number 11 that it shows
like king of queens and friends and
that those must be the only ones making
money
because the people love the shows and
they don't have to produce anything yeah
but yeah but those shows still cost
money to acquire for tnt and tbs and
those shows aren't cheap that's true uh
uh and that's why you see such a
turnover by the way what you know when
when we have these up fronts
you know you have first you have the the
the the what's been cancelled you have
the announcements of what shows are not
coming back
and then you have the upfront now now
you you know what you know what the the
purpose of the upfront is correct no hit
me
well the purpose of the upfront
is and and the upfronts have gotten more
and more and more consolidated now uh
what i mean by that is nbc universal
let's take that my old boss as an
example nbc universal held there up
front on may 12th at the javits center
okay
and it wasn't just nbc universal it was
all of the networks that fall under the
nbc universal umbrella so that would be
usa network that would be sci-fi channel
that would be
e it would be esquire it would be
chiller it would be all telemundo
uh i'm excuse me univision um
you know six seven eight networks now
what they do is they all get they gather
all of the advertisers
together this is a party for the
advertisers the upfront front
because that's a a broadcast channel a
broadcasting cable channels currency
is how they uh uh raise revenue through
programming uh they raise revenue from
the advertisers
so they throw a big party for the
advertisers and they pull out all the
stops and nbc universal this year had
seth meyers
come out uh they held it at the javits
center and seth myers came out and
entertained the crowd with a few jokes
blah blah uh joel mchale
also came out uh and spoke to the crowd
and basically what they tell
the crap because the crowd is made up of
advertisers
they thank them
for their support
thank you for your continued support
thank you for your advertising dollars
and
here is our slate
of upcoming programming
for you to check out so that we can
continue to do business together
and that's the purpose of the upfront is
to bring in the advertisers
thank them for their support and then
show them what you have coming around
the corner
so that they can invest more dollars in
your in your network
that's basically what the upfronts are
and it's usually a great party i in the
20 years that i worked for sci-fi
um i only went to two up front
um
basically the reason being was because
this was this was before the
consolidating
occurred you know like sci-fi would have
its own upfront separate from
uh usa network
separate from
e separate from chiller you know well no
sci-fi chile used to do this together
but um
all the cable networks used to do their
separately now
we live in a climate where you know i
just rattled off
seven channels owned by one company
uh you know you have nbc usa sci-fi
chiller esquire e
univision you have all under seven eight
nine channels under one owner okay
so it just makes sense to throw one
party
now what do you think uh
about like they did at the beacon
theater in manhattan fox held theirs
oh and they had ryan seacrest
open
and make an and and address the crowd so
it's it's a way for advertisers to see
the celebs
to see the stars
you know to to
to try one on a little bit have some
good food it's it's a big schmooze fast
basically
what do you think like is it possible
now because i mean when you think of
advertisers the whole reason they don't
have swearing on tv is because it would
upset the advertisers do you think that
like and like i don't know if like let's
say screen box had an upfront
could you could like could you have
swearing and then and still get
advertisers that would that would lock
on and you could still make money as
opposed to not having to having nothing
nothing on tv now because god forbid an
advertiser drops out
all right that's a great question that's
a great question because what that
allows me to do is to clarify something
okay
there were two business models out there
there is the broadcast model which
relies on advertisers for their revenue
and then there's the subscription model
and the subscription model is like hbo
stars
uh
encore
uh showtime
okay
in in the subscription world there's no
advertising
they make their money
they make their money through
subscription
okay so there's no ads there's no
there's promos
for material that appears on their own
network but there's no burger king no
brillo and biscuits right
so screen box is falls under that model
of subscription and that's one of the
things that has me thrilled about being
part of the team at screenbox
is that there's no more ratings there's
no more advertisers there's no more
censoring
uh uh because we're subscriber base
the movies
you watch the movies with all of the
language all of you watch the movie the
way it was made the way it was meant to
be watched
we don't approach
uh advertisers that scream box we
probably will for the website
uh uh but the main source of revenue is
subscription
that's amazing because last week
when i did douglas movies
we were talking about
when you watch a movie on tv and instead
of saying [ __ ] they say crap
but sometimes let's say ray leota is the
one that's saying it they can't get ray
and they get like lead to say just say
crap
and at the end of ray liottas and you
sit there and go jesus christ what am i
watching you know it's like watching uh
scarface on tbs or something uh
yeah it does feel like the dark ages
we've we've definitely evolved and that
is a problem that the the the
broadcasters and the cablers have is
that they still
well you see they fall the broadcast
networks fall under the regulations of
the fcc
because their material is free over the
airwaves you could go to radio shack and
spend fifty dollars on a digital antenna
put it up on your roof and boom you get
all the networks a gorgeous 1080i
by definition
so they're held to a standard
regulated by the government
the cable industry is not
regulated by the fcc
in in so much that
uh as far as content goes the cable
industry so more or less polices itself
okay with the exception of hbo stars in
showtime those guys are all you know my
god you ever watch spartacus i hate to
go off topic for a second but do you
ever watch spartacus no on showtime
holy [ __ ] let me tell you something
that show would have a hard time earning
an r rating if they went out into the
theaters theatrically
jesus christ between the bloodletting
the gore and the masturbation
there's no way
there's no way that they would get an r
rating in the theaters but because
they're showtime because their business
model is a transaction between a
subscriber and
the company
um they don't fall under those fcc
guidelines
they don't fall under those fcc
regulations i should say
so um so the networks do it because they
have to because the government tells
themselves they can be fined
by the government
and and we've seen these cases happen
bono share howard stern uh we've seen
these cases
where you know if someone drops an
f-bomb
you know the fcc is going to find you
for that
let me ask you something ray i'm really
interested in that
i have a friend a comedian friend
i've known this and she was answering
the phones
at the [ __ ] improv in dallas
that's how long i know cristela alonso
cristela alonso show got picked up last
week by abc
this is a spanish girl that came out
here
got a job writing on the carlos mancilla
show
wrote uh when that ended she went on her
own did comedy i seen her on sons of
anarchy
she got shot in the head she did a
couple episodes or some shows
she went to montreal and got a deal
she's a spanish girl so they gave her a
weird deal you know they gave her an abc
a 100 000 flat or something and pay as
you go along
which everybody else they'll give you
you know whatever you want 250 000 and
they gave this girl nothing but it was
uh if they write a script we'll give you
30 000.
if the script goes to pilate we'll give
you another 100 000. if the pilot gets
picked up then you get the [ __ ] world
so yeah
oh my god i am so happy for her um the
name of the show's like cristela and
gabriel glaciers plays her boyfriend
really she knows gabriel gabriel and her
been on the road for years yeah
cristela's a neat girl and i mean when i
saw the trailer i was so [ __ ] happy
but
here's the thing right ready
they gave it they gave like the [ __ ]
10 o'clock slot on friday nights on abc
now everybody knows that's like that's a
smack that's a tough night but
in this society it really isn't right
because somebody like lee will tape that
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah and go out and
watch it all on sunday when he watches
uh what else did you tell louie
shark tank is on friday night too that's
right for like four or five years yeah
that's one of my favorites too but this
yeah now when you dvr a show is that
part of ratings still like if 50 million
people dvr cristela and don't watch it
as it's getting air
does it still count as a view
will abc cancel her if everybody dvr's
the show
uh
yes yes and yes um uh uh it it counts
okay when you dvr a program it counts
but it it
that uh it goes into a different bucket
all right and i'll and i'll try to
explain uh we'll try we'll try and we'll
we'll figure we'll make this three
different buckets
one bucket is live
viewing
okay and live viewing means
uh your sporting events
the news
and award shows
okay
because most award shows are live events
the oscars uh what did we have last
night the billboard billboard okay
okay so
live viewing is where a network or a
cable network
uh has its strongest strongest dollars
is in live viewing they want you to
watch them live now
let's say last night you were watching
the billboard awards and you had to go
make up the schedule
okay you had to go to the back house and
make a fish
and you freeze you paused the live
broadcast
the moment you do that you fall into the
second bucket
okay the second bucket is time shifted
viewing
even though you hit the pause button
and
that pause button
is you know you you go make a pistol you
come back 45 seconds to a minute later
you are now time delayed
all right and that's the second bucket
then the third bucket
would be
uh plus seven which which means that
you ended up watching it within seven
days of its original broken
and that's the lat and that's the third
bucket so there's three different
buckets each bucket has a different
value
to the cable company live being the
highest value
because you're probably fast forwarding
through commercials if you record it
um so i say again because you're
probably fast forwarding through
commercials if you record it
oh yeah absolutely yeah now again
these numbers are only generated by
nielsen homes and and i don't know if we
touched on this the last time we spoke
but you know like coco nolan's unless
you're in a selected nielsen home no
one's looking at your dvr yeah that's
the biggest [ __ ] thing now anyways
with all with all the digital stuff so
unless you have a nielsen box i don't
know how they're getting these numbers
like they pick a couple people to give a
nielsen box and then they just
extrapolate from those numbers so they
have no idea who's watching anything now
who gets a neilson box and who judges
who gets one they do well um i would say
right about now and boy if there are any
other broadcasters or folks listening
they can certainly correct anything i'm
i'm saying but i would think i think the
last time i noticed
it's about 20 000 homes right now in the
united states
are official nielsen homes so those 20
000 households those those people are
basically dictating what the rest of the
world is watched with the rest of the
united states excuse me uh what the rest
of the united states is watching i i
think there's over a hundred million
homes with cable
currently right now
and 20 000 of those homes on nielsen
homes you're selected by
uh your location you're selected by your
income you're selected by how many
people are in the household
um you are selected by um
well those three things primarily where
you live
uh what your income is and how many
people are in the household i'm sure
that there are more factors than that
but for this discussion i'm trying to
keep it simple
um then what they do is they measure the
viewing habits of those 20 000
households
and
they yield a result they say uh through
their matrix to the way that they do
their math they can extrapolate as
you've said uh the information and say
this many people watched the billboard
music awards last night now how old is
that system because it would be like if
let's say over the weekend joey had 300
people at one show it'd be it'd be like
getting comment cards from five people
and maybe you just gave those cards to
the five people who didn't want to be
there anyways
like it seems like with all the internet
stuff now that we could probably
actually know who's watching what and
then we wouldn't have
two and a half men on for 10 years
because just a couple random people who
got the nielsen box liked it
yeah you know i mean that's the argument
that has existed from day one
but even even before the digital age
uh there were many many many people
inside and outside of the industry that
felt that the numbers simply didn't hold
up that the numbers don't add up that
the sample was simply too small
um like you said you know it's like
handing out five
uh q a cards to a room of 300 people
it's almost like taking a baseball
players
one single time at that and making that
single time at that his average for the
season
you know yeah
i don't get the system and i i feel bad
for people who do tv shows now because
they could do a great tv show
and just maybe they maybe they don't
give
people maybe they don't give people who
are horror fans
nielsen boxes so the horror show goes
off the air now it's just uh
yes i mean i mean
and for many many decades
this system has worked but on the other
hand
you can also say well it was also the
only system in town
you know yeah it was the only game in
town now here in the digital age
advertisers and by the way now there's
also c3 c3 is the rating
that is given to commercials
commercials are rated now
um i i remember back in the day when
dvrs were just coming on board
and advertisers were livid
they're like hey look if uh if it's
being dvr'd people are not watching the
commercials
so what nielsen did was nielsen turned
around and develop the matrix that
simply measures the commercials to tell
the advertisers hold your horses
calm down here are the numbers people
are actually watching your commercials
okay so that's even another bucket but i
don't want to get done i don't want i
don't want to
confuse these [ __ ]
i don't want to get too complicated in
the discussion but what's going on right
now in the digital era is that
advertisers
are screaming for a new matrix for a new
unit of measure
a central one coming from nielsen
however
most advertisers are using their own
matrixes now anyway so i'm not quite
sure how uh a a single a single
uniform
unit of a way of measuring uh the
digital audience i i i don't see that
much happening because most advertisers
just use their own
their own matrixes at this point now
anyway so um so it's a little bit so so
it's much much much tougher
when you see a show get cancelled
and and this is the old programmer
programmer in me talking now
but the show gets cancelled because
people don't watch it
i mean that that's it at the end of the
day
uh i i know that our audiences would
like to think that
programmers shove things down your
throat
but not today uh we're reactionary
programmers we react to what people
respond to
okay and if people go to a show coco
coco you know this you're on stage if
people go to a show and they don't like
the show they see they don't come back
you're right
right i'm the same is true of television
but how does a show where robin williams
not work at a perfect time slot this
guy's been on tv for 40 [ __ ] years i
mean we grew up on robin williams is it
because it's too competitive or the show
is just aren't getting good anymore or
well he probably didn't come cheap
okay right
okay
so
that that show has to bring in a certain
amount of revenue for it to be a success
which means that it has to hit a certain
number and if it doesn't and and if it
doesn't hit that number if people don't
watch it
then the network has to make a decision
hey look robin williams is costing us x
amount of dollars the show is not
yielding the ratings that we've promised
to advertisers
so we gotta let the show go
and that's what happens uh uh nothing
lasts forever in television i think
except maybe 60 minutes in the simpsons
that's about it
it's crazy how attached you get to shows
too like that thing with community that
just happened
like and even when like regular shows
get canceled you get it gets sad for a
second then you realize like why am i
saying that tv shows ending but
it's weird how attached people get to it
we all have that we are i'm amazed
community lasted as long as it did oh
yeah i think that that's really to be
honest um i think it's a testament to
the people at nbc universal because it
wasn't really doing all that well but
they stuck with it
and and you don't see that too often
nowadays things get cancelled
quickly man you got you got three
you got three episodes
especially when i can put beverly hills
housewives on
you know we could put a reality show you
know of something and they get ratings
and even it's too quick
a seinfeld wouldn't have lasted 10 years
ago they wouldn't have given it two
seasons
you know not in in 2005 they were
cutting you on the third [ __ ] episode
i remember the tracy morgan show you
remember the tracy morgan show on nbc no
three episodes you know uh
joe joe panther joe patliano had a show
one at one year right about
the beginning of they went through
everybody they went through every
combination uh what's his name lo what's
his name lo they put him on
rob lowe had a show his fail what they
do they put joe pants and rob blow
together on friday night that show
failed you know they don't keep you
around they don't give you i'm surprised
blue bloods has lasted on cbs with tom
selleck as long as you know with
moynihan you look at these shows and you
you know a guy like me i'm interested
why has that lasted and why hasn't this
lasted who you know i came from a
society where we didn't watch tv on the
front what we did growing up we watched
sampling sun at eight and chico in the
man at 8 30. you know and then you went
out and then you had miami [ __ ] vice
at nine o'clock so you had to tell the
dealer not to come over till 10 15.
because miami advice ended at 10 you
couldn't wait to [ __ ] do a line of
blow you know there was all these i
wasn't caught up as much back yeah i
know you had you know 60 channels and
it's so crowded today it is so crowded
today man i mean to make a hit and and
friday nights by the way
uh i i i there's a there's a term called
hot levels
okay hot levels are houses using
television okay
and friday night
has the lowest hot levels of the week
your worst your worst nights for
television
uh television viewership where there are
fewer people sitting in front of the tv
on friday nights and saturdays
okay
so um what would what do you two think
would be the best nights
mondays maybe wet on tuesdays
watch season thursday the best night
isn't thursday wednesday and monday
sundays and mondays are your best or the
highest pot levels
you have the majority of folks
poems using television
sunday night and monday night and what
always runs on sunday nights
award shows
from the oscars
to the billboard awards to the american
music awards you look you normally see
your award shows on sunday nights
because of the hi-hat levels and you
also see a lot of your big mini series
events
when history channel did the bible
and uh uh uh all of these big uh the
rosemary's uh baby
uh coming from nbc
it's a sunday night and a monday night
because they're hedging their bets
because more people will be in front of
that televisions on those nights so to
your friend who's getting a show on abc
on a friday night at 10 o'clock
she's got a bit of an uphill battle
right no no no i know that i know that
that's why and i love it at that time
i want to support her on the show she's
a you know i can't believe it happened
they give all these stars these shows
and this girl
found the writer you know you for you to
get your show on the air
so many stars have to align
yes you know so many stars have to align
you can have the best show
go in front of an audience the thing
sucks and there you are so many stars
have to align so
i'm very happy for ray when is your uh
you so your new web page launches july
15th you said
this is this is the information i have
at the moment july 15th screen box is
going to really become a much more
robust
experience and and it will be available
on multiple platforms that people are
accustomed
to a subscriber uh uh to to us to to a
subscription sort of model
uh there was a wonderful announcement
from xbox i think about a week ago uh a
week or two ago wonderful announcement
from xbox they are no longer going to be
charging
uh uh the uh
xbox gold membership in order to get to
their pay channels
in order to get to the xbox pay channels
you needed to be a member of xbox gold
and they're removing that wall now
they're removing that wall so that you
don't have to be an xbox gold member in
order to gain access to netflix and the
other page services that are available
on xbox so that's wonderful news for me
that's wonderful news
uh for screen box i should say and then
um
the other piece of news
uh that was also uh uh uh well i have a
mixed feeling about it because i have
good friends there but uh uh fearnet
is uh no longer gonna be around they're
going dark they're going black uh
comcast
fear net was a horror was a horror movie
channel
and it was owned by several companies
i think it was lionsgate and
mgm i'm not sure i'm blanking i'm sure
that folks out there know better than me
they're yelling at me right now but uh
uh a film that was owned by several
companies and comcast was one of them
comcast who've been
bought out its partners
it now owns fearnet outright and it's
going to um
it's good it's going to eliminate the
channel and the programming that exists
on fearnet is going to be divided
between sci-fi channel and chiller
now this makes me very happy
uh it makes me very happy because uh
there's a void
now a void that needs to be filled
uh avoid that sci-fi channel and chiller
can't sell
because they're advertiser-based
they're the old business model
okay whenever you tune in to chiller for
horror movies guess what folks
here comes the commercial break gonna
bounce you out of the horror
and all of the language and all of the
violence
and whatever nudity exists is going to
be eliminated
okay and that's why it's a vod world
that is why
the shift is happening because the
audience is demanding it horror fans
don't want horror movies white washed or
saturated they don't want any movie
white watchers
crawler fans don't want horror movies
sanitized and that's what you get when
you watch horror on tv at the moment now
walking dead in american horror story
are two excellent shows
but i can't watch them with the
commercial breaks i wait till netflix i
wait till later because the commercial
breaks bounce me out of the hall it's
disruptive
i can't take it
so when does your page kick off july
15th
july 15th yeah yeah july 15th we're very
very very excited and this was really
the original design for screen box from
from my understanding when i was when i
was asked to join the team um my
understanding was that uh the original
launch for screen box was supposed to be
on xbox
and that was always the goal that was
always the intent
and for reasons uh i'm not clear about
uh it won't fund youtube instead
but the xbox launch is now coming so
this is really where we wanted to be
and uh we're very much prepared for it
and we're very excited about it i'm i'm
thrilled personally
i'm thrilled because i'm i'm able to
give horror fans
content the way it's supposed to be
watched
not through someone else's filter i
don't want to watch a horror film
through someone else's filter i want to
see the film the filmmaker made
you're like the fidel castro of [ __ ]
horror films you used to drag me down to
jersey city 40 years ago to watch all
that craziness ray we're going to have
you back
we're going to have you back on on july
14th to promote this if you don't mind
ray i love you
you're [ __ ] knowledgeable as [ __ ] the
people are happy today
uh it was great seeing you and your
brother together at the stress factory
uh
it really hit home
together fantastic
folks if you haven't gone out to see
joey diaz yet live man
dan you're missing out you might as well
might as well be living in a cave what a
show let me tell you something my ribs
hurt dude my ribs hurt from laughing so
goddamn when we talked about the [ __ ]
kid with the pointy ears growing up
vinnie warhead the kid that [ __ ]
used to like the fires he was uh
he was a volunteer fireman he used to
light the fires and get there first
yeah folks folks let me tell you when
you go see joey on stage and he's
telling you
about his friends growing up
he's not he's not kidding
we were [ __ ] around
i gasped in the audience
because i'm hearing names of people i
know
and situations and i just and i guessed
because i'm like oh [ __ ] i know this
person um folks when you go see when you
go see joey you seem the real
deal the real deal
i can guarantee that
i love you uncle ray i'll give you a
call during the week give your brother a
kiss for me and uh
thank you as always i love you buddy
thank you for being my friend for 45
[ __ ] my brother always asks for you
he misses him we love you very very very
much i love you guys i'm really really
proud of you dude i'm proud of you guys
that you're still in my corner man stay
blackish
and we'll be in touch
i shall i'm black and proud i say it
loud
ow hit me hit me stay black i love you
[ __ ] lee love you too stay well
all right brother he's [ __ ] great
he really is he is i learned something
every time i talk to that [ __ ]
lunatic that vapor hit me a little bit
it's supposed to [ __ ] hit you what do
you think this is where's life where's
tony better that's what i'm talking
about we're forgetting about everything
steps ahead
we love you people a little something
for your monday morning we're always
around
when
somebody breaks your heart
are you [ __ ] kidding me we're always
there
we're all together [ __ ] these
[ __ ]
we own this place
it's over
no more [ __ ] around
i'm stoned to anything
i'm thinking about that [ __ ] one egg
and that piece of wheat color oh yeah
i hope tony bennett has like a web guy
who will eventually go to this youtube
page for this one
i'm sorry just talk over it
and he goes and he looks at all the
comments and like he figures it out
what the [ __ ] are they talking about
church grab your balls
mr bennett i wanna be around are you
[ __ ] kidding me
let's see
if the puzzle
fits what's the story lisa let's blast
these [ __ ] with some on it
always on it i was just in austin i
talked to harvey but we didn't connect
and i feel really bad but it doesn't
matter when i got back
i did my on at 120 and i'm [ __ ] back
i took a little three-hour nap and uh as
usual shroom tech uh strong bone the
digestive enzymes
listen if you're not [ __ ] around
without at least giving it a try you're
slipping i'm telling you this is
sincerely as can be you know if you
gotta open up a little alpha brain just
to see how it makes you feel go with
alpha brain it's got a money back
guarantee they've got the kettlebells
they've got the [ __ ] kettlebells the
double faces on them they got the ropes
listen i'm talking about supplements
here give it a shot you got nothing to
lose you know columbus take a [ __ ]
chance it's monday go to honor.com go to
the box and press church go to
joeydears.net look at the tour dates
look at the t-shirts while you're there
go to the on it box go look it on it see
what they got to offer put what in the
[ __ ] box for the
r
church
h get your ten percent off you have the
mailing list if you want to join up for
the for the uh stay on it they'll mail
it to you at the first of the month it's
a great deal okay hulu plus as usual is
what ray was talking about this morning
websites like hulu plus huluplus.com
they're [ __ ] tremendous okay we don't
[ __ ] around i read you the shows the
other day i tell you what they got on
you can watch them anytime movies kids
shows documentaries game whatever the
[ __ ] you need hulu plus has it why [ __ ]
around with all this other [ __ ] and pay
too much i'm asking you for 7.99 a month
but i'm giving you two weeks for free
7.99 a month but we're gonna give you
two weeks to get your [ __ ] money's
worth see what it's got to offer you see
the order they come in how it works boom
bam and then after that it's 799. go to
joeydiaz.net go to hulu plus box and
press press joey like a [ __ ]
that you are j-o-e-y
start with hulu plus today they've got
shark tank they've got just just so many
[ __ ] shows it's just too many it's a
great thing all rolled up into one my
wife lives on it she watches it on a
roku you can watch it on multiple
devices iphone ipad knock yourself the
[ __ ] out you could even watch it off of
if you look at the moon at night they
got hulu plus on the [ __ ] moon on the
side you follow me some they'll have
something on it only you just get to see
that only jews get to see that go to
huluplus.com go to joeydears.net go to
the hulu plus box and press in joey boom
there you go watch your favorite shows
all different devices 7.99 a month you
can't beat that number three dollar
shave club come on
that's it
you know what i'm sick of telling you
[ __ ] for a dollar six dollars
and nine dollars a month i i don't have
to sell this i'm telling you this is
your [ __ ] uncle get cut this [ __ ]
it's one dollar six dollars and nine
dollars you get brand new raises
delivered to your house monthly they
send you an email so you can sit out
there and watch for the [ __ ] mailman
to come boom we'll put it right in your
hand you get your four [ __ ] razors
one blade single blade the other package
comes with an aloe strip on it you can't
lose nine dollars six dollars one dollar
a month either of those packages will
work for you they also got the one wipe
charlies they also got the [ __ ] shave
butter you're not gonna lose with this
[ __ ] i'm telling you right now try the
six dollar package okay just try them
let me know what the [ __ ] you think
you're not gonna be sorry go to
joeydears.net go to the uh dollar shave
club box and press in church church c-u
c-h-u-r-c-h
also to my buddies at escapepodtank.com
all i hear are great things from them
great things from people that do
business with them go to escape.tank.com
get the just off the rank model what's
the name of it the just just the tank
model you got 150 off let me tell you
something about these guys i got 800
number there you got any problems any
questions with rotation tanks jeremy is
always there to answer whatever [ __ ]
question you got that's how solid he is
this is a customer service based company
if you don't want they have industrial
tanks they got residential tanks they
got commercial tanks they'll send them
to your [ __ ] house you call the
plumber let him install it or they'll
fly out and install it for you mention
joeydears.net get a deuce and a half off
where you're gonna get that type of
action call jeremy today on the 809 line
escape
i also want to give love to everybody
who gives us [ __ ] love from my girl
lori ortega sergio's wife to shannon fox
i love you for having this your
husband's [ __ ] corner to sam graziano
to my beautiful [ __ ] hooky spooky for
coming down constance andrew and yaznid
for the beautiful [ __ ] car and the
thing i don't know i pronounced her name
correctly please tweet me and tell me
the name and i'll pronounce it again
you're a beautiful couple and you're
beautiful people a lot of you people
that came to austin i [ __ ] love you
man dead squad nation stand up take your
dick out tell them all to [ __ ] sniff
that helmet
joshua machiukis know me
machockey
joshua mccalkey i [ __ ] love you and
that's panos i'll see you soon
[ __ ] but uh
i think i'm gonna talk to lee uh and
we're gonna start a new podcast once a
week called the church advice
and we're gonna give you a number and uh
you're gonna call with your problem or
whatever you have on your mind you have
to give your name you have to give your
number nothing like that
we're not going to take your number
we're not going to call you back we
don't give a [ __ ] i know a lot of people
have questions that are deep and maybe
uh you want to talk them out with myself
and lee
so we're going to get a number today and
we'll let you know when that's going to
start up because i get [ __ ] great
emails
and listen man the emails and what we
talk about on the show go hand in hand
but i just want to dedicate a show i
think once or twice a month to the
[ __ ] people from the church that have
a [ __ ] question about their life man
and maybe me or leo will get somebody
else and this isn't to laugh at you or
the goof on you you know i got a great
one yesterday about some kid said that
uh i got two great ones yesterday
about uh
a kid who called who hit me up and said
he's a salesman you know he's getting
into cars and he's learning a lot and
it's hard
and he said you know joey i always hear
you talk about it what's the best advice
you give me i told them you know follow
up
send cards send thank you cards don't
hang out with the [ __ ] in the
circle and do what they don't do
do opposite of what they do
you know be your own person as a
salesman but the most important thing
is to keep your shoes shined
because when you shine your shoes you're
ready for the day you're letting your
mind know that you're ready for the
[ __ ] day you ain't [ __ ] around we
don't shine our shoes enough and i'm
guilty of that [ __ ] when i go out and i
see a salesman i look at his shoes and i
get [ __ ] depressed and you guys are
looking at me going joy what are you
talking about let me tell you something
it all starts with shining your [ __ ]
shoes in the morning you shine your own
[ __ ] anybody could take it to some
[ __ ] puerto rican or some white dude
or some black dude at a train station
anybody could do that i'm talking about
you yourself as a human being putting
your thing on putting that [ __ ] black
gunk on or a brown duck and shining your
shoes it does something to your attitude
listen man leah tell you i [ __ ] hate
everything all right i have a great time
with lee i haven't but every morning i
talk about the word love because if you
[ __ ] say it you'll believe it
throughout the day you know every day i
tell somebody i love him and i see him
looking at me like wow
because they hear it and they go why
would he say that hmm you know maybe
something whatever it all starts with
the little [ __ ] things you know and i
believe that i had a a
manager wayne means
and he used to say that when you shine
your own shoes you believe in yourself
it's a weird way of believing in
yourself
and uh these are just little anecdotes i
picked up and i paid attention to and i
see what they're talking wayne means was
a biker half the year and the other half
the year he was a [ __ ] car salesman
but when you worked with wayne means
your income went up
everybody's income went up two three
thousand dollars a month
because he attacked different things
that we didn't attack in normal he was a
biker guys he's a [ __ ] biker with a
long hair and a beard and a harley and
an old lady and tattoos but six months
of a year he [ __ ] shaved his head he
shaved his head trimmed his beard he
took off his glasses because he goes i
want them to see my beautiful blue eyes
this guy was an amazing man
when i went to prison he was [ __ ]
amazing wayne means i mean
uh
when the cops went looking for me he
gave me wrong address he used to call me
brother he used to call me the renegade
and he used to tell you know he believed
in me and sometimes when somebody has a
weird belief in you he was a car
salesman this guy had no reason he was a
[ __ ] he was a [ __ ] nomad six
months a year but 600 months a year to
keep his sanity
he would just [ __ ]
change himself completely and he would
go into he would become corporate it was
the most amazing thing
and he'd come over to me and go this is
what and i'd wait for him i worked for
him for three years i worked from the
suzuki store for a walk in south suzuki
they kept tipping
yeah [ __ ] those suzukis they kept
tipping over
you remember those things the little
bikes yeah no the [ __ ]
that's how old i am oh the cars yeah
and then he went to the subaru store and
i learned more
in those six months about sales but i
don't know stop laughingly let me get a
water i got cotton
from the hemorrhoid medication uh
it's it's very amazing and that's one
thing he used to say brother you gotta
shine your shoes brother you gotta look
sharp you gotta feel like a million
[ __ ] bucks to make a million bucks
so if you take anything from today's
show
shine your pho oh here comes [ __ ]
donald trump and the construction crew
again
it's [ __ ] kaputs to the podcast
one thing it's the [ __ ] other part of
your nuts today people it's gonna be a
hot one we love you listen let me give
you some dates i'm gonna be at the ice
house
may 28th next wednesday we got a great
guest that next thursday night me and
lee are going to san diego we're going
to be at harrah's at nine o'clock eating
steak
selling t-shirts [ __ ] around patches
the whole thing
june sixth and seventh i met wise guys
with the great drunken talk
duncan trussell
one of the best go headlining shows
you'll see this year wiseguys.com go get
the tickets this is a goofy podcast shut
the [ __ ] up cocksuck it's always a goofy
podcast and governor's long island three
days in june get your tickets
joeydears.net for your [ __ ] g patches
t-shirts and your cups but seriously i
want to
uh
let you people know we're going to start
something called church advice
and uh we're going to just start off
gently and see how you guys like it if
you don't like it we'll get rid of it i
just think it's a good idea for people
who want to uh send me an email but not
really because i get great emails i got
another one about marriage yesterday
also that it brought a tear to my eye
the guy was getting divorced and he
couldn't believe it that he didn't do
the little things and and
like i told lee anybody could give you a
woman flowers anybody could buy you a
diamond you know it's the little things
in the relationship but i didn't know
when i was with kathy you know i talked
about mercy and my other daughter jackie
i was two different people i had two
different
expectations of life and sometimes you
got to taste [ __ ] before your life
tastes better sometimes you gotta taste
[ __ ] man before it gets better you know
and uh
with marriage and [ __ ] like that there's
relationships with lee there's a
give-and-take you know yeah lee has to
know i got his back fully and i have to
know lee's got my back fully and he does
and i have his back and that's and
that's in a friendship relationship but
it also works in a in a home
relationship with your wife man i'm not
the easiest guy to live with and i know
that but i love my wife and i give her
the respect that i can and i'm home at
nights and i uh
i like other women i like looking at
[ __ ] and tits don't get me wrong that's
what part of being a man is but my
dedication to my wife is uh
and sometimes we forget that early on
when we're young it's not just going
home [ __ ] them and eating dinner with
them
you gotta do little things listen on
sundays i love to go to the open road at
gmack at vmac at my jiu jitsu school
it's [ __ ] tremendous people come from
other schools and teach you things
but it's family day i could just jiu
jitsu six [ __ ] days a week so i'm
gonna be covering [ __ ] like that on this
if you're interested twit me you know
this is something for you you know give
us a response you know hit twittly tell
me it's a great idea i'll give you a
date we're going to get a new 800 number
so you could call from wherever the [ __ ]
you got a call and we're gonna give it a
shot to church advice we'll have a
t-shirt made a patch maybe we'll send
you a sticker to say that you called in
you know whatever the [ __ ] you could put
him in your window put up your ass i
don't give a [ __ ] it's monday may 19th
go out there
[ __ ]
swing from the [ __ ] fences and let
them know who [ __ ] sent you you're a
bad [ __ ] don't let them tell you
otherwise i want to give a shout out to
ray cannell and all my sponsors on it
dollar shave club hulu plus
uh escape podtank.com nailed it life and
naturesbox.com for and my biggest
sponsors you bad [ __ ] for
loving us have a great day stay black
and do your thing don't let nobody [ __ ]
with you now that the show's over don't
forget to sign up for your free trial of
hulu plus hulu plus that's binge on
thousands of hit shows anytime anywhere
on your tv pc smartphone or tablet
support this podcast and get an extended
free trial of hulu plus when you go to
huluplus.com joey or go to joeydiaz.net
and click on the hulu plus banner and
don't forget to sign up for
dollarshaveclub.com get high quality
razors sent to your door every month for
a fraction of what you pay at retail now
go to dollarshaveclub.com forward slash
church or just go to joeyds.net and
click on the dollar shave club banner
and thank you escape podtank.com get
your sensory deprivation tank they have
a couple different models they'll set it
up for you mention joey diaz and you're
going to save an additional 250 dollars
i will never understand the society